From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013. My name is Willie Griffin and I am a research associate with the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am with Willie Griffin John Bishop and Albany Georgia on the campus of Albany State University University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here today with Mrs. Mary Jenkins who played a role in the local Albany movement.
Thank you so much, Ms. Jenkins, for being here and agreeing to share your story with the Civil Rights History Project.
Thank you for accepting me.
Okay, can we begin with you stating your full name, date and place of birth?
My name is Mary Francis Jenkins.
I just missed that, I was in that.
And you were born when?
I was born in Waycross, Georgia, where county?
Okay, I was the date of your birth.
Oh, August 12, 1928.
Okay, it's August 12, 1928.
So you were born in Waycross, Georgia, how long did you spend in Waycross, Georgia before the year?
Well, not many years. When I was very young, I lived in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
My father was killed in automobile accident on Georgia highway.
And when my mother remarried, we moved to Albany, Georgia.
Okay. And how old were you when you moved to Albany, Georgia?
When I moved to Albany, Georgia? Yeah, about how old were you?
Oh, I was about eight or nine.
I remember I entered the fourth grade.
Okay, okay. So when you came to Albany, what was the city like?
Do you remember anything about it?
Well, yes, I remember a lot about it.
Okay.
I grew up in the Jim Crow era.
I sat in the balcony of the Albany movie theater.
I drank from the separate water fountain.
So I know a lot about segregation as it existed.
I remember when I was very young walking through the crests, ten-sens total.
And my mother was holding tightly to my hand.
And a little white boy just about my age walked up and squirted a water pistol in my face.
And I tried desperately to get away from my mother so that I could catch him.
But she kept saying, you can't.
And pretty much you can't has followed my life.
You know, when my daughter was three years old, I took her to Teapar.
And she saw some white children getting on buses.
Well, they were rides for them.
And she said, money, I want to ride on that.
And I had to say the same thing to her.
That my mother said to me, you can't.
And she turned around and beat her little fist against me.
And she said, you don't want me to ride.
How was I to explain the system to her?
So that meant that I had to take the blame.
Okay.
So, do you think, I mean, do you know that your mother was probably trying to protect you?
Oh, definitely, definitely.
Anytime that we were in some sort of white situation, she was clinging, you know, to me.
And I knew that.
So, beyond those, what else do you remember?
Those memories of I should mother, what else do you remember about her in terms of her bringing you up
and the other mess, and she tried instilling you as a person?
Oh, well, she, well, one thing I do know, she definitely wanted me to have a good education.
She never finished high school.
Okay.
And so she was definitely trying to convince me that education is the key to everything you want.
And your, so what was your mother primarily at homemaker?
She was primarily at homemaker.
Okay. And you said she was remarried, so your stepfather, what was his profession?
Stepfather worked on the (Atlantic) Coast Line Railroad.
Okay.
What position?
So we always could travel.
Oh, okay.
Half-fat.
That's always good.
So, the schools that you attended, what was the first schools that you attended?
Madison High School.
Madison High School was all segregated, all black school that I attended.
And of course, by being a segregated school, we received hand-me-down books.
The equipment was not the modern kind for that day.
But I think we had the best teachers in the world.
Who were some of the most memorable teachers?
Oh, okay.
Miss Ruth T. Kimball, what happened to be the first, like, principal, female principal?
Okay.
And Dordi Caldwell.
And what do you remember about her?
I remember that she was very strict, and that you had to follow policies.
I remember that quite well.
Okay.
And, um, were there any other teachers?
Well, I had Miss Rimmel's as a home economics teacher.
Okay.
Miss Thelma French, who was also a home economics teacher.
Miss Olive Rogers was my English teacher, and many others.
Okay.
So, what do you remember about the instruction of the teachers?
Were they, I mean, were they very protective of the students or did they?
You know, you said they would dissonant with disciplinarians and others, while others were mentors.
And so forth.
You know, we don't have problems that they have.
Right.
You know, we didn't have the problems that they have today.
Thank God.
But, um, yes, they discipline us.
We did things that were wrong.
But we didn't have, well, we could have corporate punishment, but it wasn't brutal or abusive,
you know, in any way.
And it was never a type of person.
Well, no, it just fortunate that I wasn't really.
Okay.
While I was there, I served on many committees.
I was the editor-in-chief of the high school annual, my senior year.
Okay.
And, um, what other, what, do you remember any of your close friends from school that you,
did you stay in touch with, stayed close to them?
Yes, I have a very different, um, Vashti Stubbs.
Vashti Stubbs?
We were very close friends.
I remember when I was giving the, um, salutatorian.
And as I sat there waiting for my turn, I was so nervous.
And she took my hand.
And when I got up, I guess I did just fine because I wasn't as nervous.
Okay.
So when you graduate, so you, you, you're going to become the salutatorian of Madison High School,
and you graduate, um, did you know at that point that you wanted to be a teacher?
Or...
I think, I think I always wanted to follow in the footsteps of those who taught me.
Okay.
And you decided on a teacher?
And I decided on being a teacher.
Okay.
Uh, at one point, I really wanted to be a writer.
I wanted to write novels, fiction novels.
But that didn't work out too well.
Who was some of your favorite novels that you were reading the time, do you recall?
At that time, my goodness.
And they were right on the tip of my tongue to hear, think about it.
That's okay.
Um, now you decided to go to Fisk University who, um, directed you and...
Well, I had a teacher, um, that thought that Fisk might be a good school, um, little arts.
A little arts school.
And, um, I had to consider it, you know, a great deal financially, you know, even though
it wasn't an expensive at schools or now.
Right.
And I had to go to any of my parents made it possible for me to attend.
Okay.
So this is the first time you're away from home and you're in Nashville, Tennessee.
It was.
Well, at that age, it was the first time.
Right.
Yes.
And what was that experience like?
Were you?
Well, you know, my first year of there, in fact, it's amazing that when I arrived on the
campus of Fisk, you wouldn't believe it.
Almost the first day, they thrust", um, um, a petition in my hand.
They wanted to get rid of a teacher.
Oh, wow.
And I didn't even know the teacher had never met her, but they were so persuasive that I
signed it.
But fortunately, they didn't succeed.
And later, she was the best teacher that I ever had.
Oh, wow.
Who was the teacher?
I do.
What did she teach?
Well, she was in the, or she was in the, um, little theater.
Okay.
Because I did belong to the little theater while I was there.
I took creative writing.
Yes.
Okay.
What other, um, activities at Fisk?
Were you involved in?
Well, mainly the writing, other than my sorority.
Okay.
But mainly, um, the creative writing activities, um, I did place with the little theater.
In fact, my senior year, um, my grade came from directing a play that was written by one of my teachers.
Okay.
Um, um, okay.
Um, I'm not begging you that though.
You know, okay.
Um, so, um, after, after Fisk, where, where did you go?
What did you decide to do?
You graduated in 1950.
I take, I take it.
Well, you know, before I, um, I, uh, finished Fisk, I really went into the service.
I stayed two years in the service.
Okay.
I, I got married while I was in the service.
You married.
Who did you marry?
You see, I married two Jenkins.
Two Jenkins.
Right.
Roscoe Jenkins.
Okay.
And, um, so, in, what was your experience like in the service?
Well, basic training.
Basic training.
Well, something that I had to really adjust to and get used to that, (basic training) took place in Virginia.
And then I went to, uh, Fort Dix, which was, (Fort Dix's) Special Services.
And I was transferred there in station at Fort Custer.
In Michigan.
And I didn't have any problems.
So, was it, was it segregated at all?
Still was segregated?
Oh, yeah.
Still segregated.
Okay.
And you know, I had no problems.
Um, so you decided to leave.
You decided to stay after?
Yes.
I had my daughter Sherry.
And, um, I knew then that I had a responsibility that I had to have a job.
Right.
So, I decided, well, my mother's training.
Education.
Right.
And I was only half through at Fisk.
So, I decided to go back and finish.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So, after you finished, you decided to move back to Albany?
I was a little bit nervous.
Now, um, what brought you back here?
And that was Roscoe from, from Albany as well?
No, he was from North Carolina.
Okay.
But he, uh, went overseas.
And after that, you know, we divorced.
Okay.
I came home and a few years later, I married again.
And when you first came back, did you immediately pursue a job in the school system?
I did.
Uh, but what happened when I graduated from Fisk?
I had a second year of certificate.
Okay.
And the supervisor here promised me a job, but she was an elementary supervisor,
which meant that I would have had to have had, uh, elementary certificate.
Okay.
So, I went over to Albany State University University, spent a whole summer trying to get an elementary certificate.
But, um, when I finished, the supervisor had to, you know, fill the job on time.
Right.
She couldn't just wait for me.
And so, uh, my pastor, Rev. James Grant, he was a principal at East Baker High School.
Okay.
He promised me the job.
So, talk about the job.
When you came into it, was it everything that you expected?
Oh, my goodness.
Well, with the solid earliest challenges that you faced.
It was at Baker County, that I learned the power, white power, what white power could do.
And I knew that, that as soon as I could get out of Baker County, I wanted to, um,
two incidents happened.
One involved a young, a young man who somehow another got involved in some incident over a weekend.
It wasn't anything that required police.
But anyway, there were students who somehow took care of him and carried him home.
But early that morning, somehow the information had gotten to the white supervisor.
And she came over to the school and she walked into his room and she told them,
pack up.
This is your last day.
And it was.
He had no recourse.
No one to go to.
In fact, her husband was the, uh, superintendent of the, uh,
of a Baker County school superintendent of Baker County.
And so that young man lost his job without being able to defend himself.
And then the next incident that happened really happened at the end of my turn, then.
And I think it was also the year that the Supreme Court ruled on desegregation and.
Yeah, in public schools.
And, um, she came over to the school and assembled all the black teachers in the room.
And she talked, well, I don't know how long about how wrong it was for us to be together.
And she had teachers that stood up and agreed with her.
It's a black teacher.
But I kept my seat because I knew that I couldn't agree with all that she was saying.
And then at the end of her speech, she said this.
She said they may make us go to school with you.
But I would never invite one of you to my home.
I was through with Baker County.
So you left Baker County after, um, one year and you came to.
I came to, uh, Albany, uh, at Carver Junior High School.
Carb of.
A teacher at Carver Junior High School.
And how was that, how was, was it different, um, how different was it from Baker County?
Or was there much to say?
Well, I tell you one thing, it was different in the environment because actually when I taught in Baker County,
it was like a barracks, a army barracks.
Okay.
So it was quite different in the actual school building was in another place.
Well, and then I can't say that Dougherty County was any different because they were adding on.
But at that time, they had army barracks in the back of the building.
And for about two months, I think I had to teach in, in the barracks.
I didn't have a room.
And then they moved me into the, uh, Jason building to it.
Okay.
So, so, did you have chalkboards?
I mean, what did you have there?
Yeah, we had chalkboards and racers and, you know, yeah, we had.
But still hand me down second books.
Oh, yes.
I don't think it was too different, you know, in that aspect.
Okay.
How were the students?
I mean, did you have many problems out there?
Well, I had good students, some of them.
You know, I look at what is happening today.
We have gangs.
Right.
But you know, then we might have one person that could upset the whole school.
And, um, it was different then.
Okay.
And we could discipline then.
And this is what we need now.
Okay.
So, this is probably mid-1950s, 55-56s that we're talking about.
And, um, what do you know about?
Yeah, we're talking about 58-59, you know.
So, this is what things...
Just a little before the movement actually started.
Right.
So, what was taking place in the black community that before the Albany movement really took off?
You know, a lot of things were being done quietly.
We were making the kind of noise that we made during the Albany movement.
But I recall that a group of men that had a Criterion Club.
And they had gone down to the City Commission and requested that they organize a BIRacial Committee.
So that some of the problems that Black said could be resolved.
Right.
They were turned down.
And even Dr. William G. Anderson, who was president of Albany movement,
he lived in an area where when it rained sometimes they couldn't even get out of the front door.
And he had gone down and talked about the situation.
But he too was refused.
And even after the movement was organized at the very beginning,
they had three representatives that went before the City Commissioners.
And asked them to organize a BIRacial Committee.
And they were told that they had no way of doing that.
So the White...
The staff is just refused.
If everything was all White as for as the City Commissioners and the government, so to speak.
So from my understanding, some of the earliest things that these people involved from Criterion Club,
one of the things that they pointed out that they wanted to discuss was the portrayal of Blacks in the Albany Herald newspaper.
How all the news that was being reported in the Albany Herald was all negative.
And it was never any positive news about Blacks.
Well, you must remember too that the Albany Herald was owned by a White man,
a radio station owned by a White man.
So everything naturally he dictated his way.
So that, I guess, is why there are complaints even there.
We ignored.
Right.
Did you read the Albany Herald or listen to the logo radio stations at all?
Oh, yes.
What else could you do?
You don't even want to hear any news at all.
So yes, I read the Albany Herald and I listened to the TV station.
So were there any other sources of news outside of Albany, like Black news papers?
Oh, yes, we had the Southwest Georgian that was edited by Southwest Georgian.
And any other newspapers outside of the Southwest, like National Black news papers coming into the community?
No, unless now there were people who subscribed, you know.
And they were like, I think they were Americans, something of that sort.
But you had to subscribe to those papers.
So let's talk a little bit about the Albany movement itself and how you can to be involved.
Did someone approach you or did you just make the decision that you were going to listen?
Take me back to that moment when the movement was finally here in Albany.
And when you decided that you were going to participate?
Well, you know, you hear a lot of rumors about things that are going to happen before they happen.
And so I had heard that, you know, about the movement and how it was going to be organized, that kind of thing.
So I went to the first mass meeting.
Where was this mass meeting?
This was held at the Mount Zion Baptist Church under Rev. James Grant.
What do you remember about that meeting?
I remember the crowds.
I remember the singing.
I remember the crying.
And people just making an all kind of pleas, you know.
And it was an emotional meeting.
People banded together and singing along with, well, they weren't called Freedom Singers at that particular time.
But they were the leaders of Freedom of Songs like Charles Sherrod and Bernice Johnson Reagon, and Rutha Mae Harris.
And I was moved.
Because I wanted all of the, you can't take another of my life.
You can't go to this restaurant.
You can't eat in this restaurant.
I wanted all of that out of my life, not only for myself, but I wanted it out for my children.
I wanted them to have a better quality of life than I had as far as segregation was concerned.
So, after that meeting, I imagine one or two more meetings, why did you walk or came down?
And he said, we need some help in the office that was set up in Dr. William G. Anderson's house, but Martin Luther King Jr.
And so I volunteered and I worked there, you know, for the time that Dr. King had his office there.
Okay. What types of things were you doing in the office?
Well, I was answering the telephone, taking messages. And it was awesome sometimes.
It was awesome because Dr. King would walk here, throw a number in my hand.
And he said, I want to talk to such a person. They're famous people.
And he would want me to contact him.
Once he put a number in my hand that was for, oh, this calypso singer, God, I can't say that.
Harry Belafonte.
Harry Belafonte. I couldn't believe that I was going to talk to Harry Belafonte.
But I dialed the number. It's sure enough I didn't because I was told that he wasn't in, but that Dr. King would get the message.
Okay.
So there were meetings that Dr. King had with just females.
He believed that women were the movers and shakers of the world.
And I learned that he was a listener. He might pose a question.
But then he would stand back and listen to the comments that were made.
So that was quite an experience for me.
But as I sat in meeting after meeting and listened to the people who went to jail,
and then they came back to the meetings and described how they were treated in jail.
And I guess I began to think, my goodness, they know Martin Luther King Jr was here.
And they know Sherrod because he's everywhere.
I said, but you have a lot of people. People will never know what happened to them.
How they were treated, what they sacrificed for equality.
And so I began to just take notes of what some of them were saying.
Sometimes I would write on fans, I'd run out of paper in my purse.
But I just thought that there should be something about what was happening here for future generations.
And so, maybe I was thinking about children who needed to know.
And so I wrote the book.
Okay. So, do you still have those feelings about,
oh, do you have those fans that you still wrote notes on? Those fans?
You said you wrote notes of?
I've been trying to go through things that I have in my attic.
I'm trying to put them all in a box so that one day somebody might give them to the museum.
So, I think we could probably arrange that happen this weekend.
So, I guess I want to back up a little bit about what I know about Southwest Georgia
and teachers who got involved in local movements.
They were often threatened with intimidation and the threat of losing their jobs.
Did that ever happen to you?
Well, nobody officially threatened my job.
But we knew that if we were arrested, that we would be fired.
And it was also rumored that they sent people to even check car tags at the mass meetings.
So, we were all aware of that.
So, it was that decision that you made not to march and get arrested?
Even though there was one time when I thought I would.
We were in Molles Island Baptist Church and Rev. James Grant had just finished the sermon for that Sunday.
And he made the statement.
He said that after this said, I'm going to do something.
I'm going to do it for myself.
And I can do it by myself.
And he stepped out of that pool pit.
And well, people, you know, they weren't going to let them do anything by themselves.
So, there were several people who got up.
And I don't know what moved me.
I had my four-year-old son in my arms.
And I got up and got in line.
But when I got to the door, my husband was standing there.
And he gently pulled me out of the line.
And I guess I lost my spirit.
And you know, that particular day, Chief Laurie Pritchett had decided not to arrest anybody.
That could have been your moment.
That could have marched.
So, I imagine you knew a lot of other teachers who did any of the teachers who marched.
Oh, yes.
Now, when they started our integration in the school,
there were teachers who were, of course, sent into the old white schools.
And some of the experiences that they had were very humiliating, not so long.
Okay.
Because some of them, in one school, the black teachers had a whole home by themselves.
Nobody teaches there at all.
And when grading time came, in some schools, they would have to carry the report cards to the principal
so that he could see whether the white students had been given the proper grades.
So there were a lot of humiliating incidents that occurred.
So you were getting ready to talk about your decision to write the book,
Open Themselves (Mary Frances Jenkins, self-published) — title verification flagged: A Pictorial History of the Albany Civil Rights Movement: A Pictorial History of the Albany Civil Rights Movement about the Albany movement.
What prompted you to want to do that?
I mean, you always mentioned that you wanted to be a novelist.
I wanted to be a writer, and I can imagine that is why I was prompted to take notes
about what was happening.
I wanted it to be a book, but at that time I really wasn't thinking of it being a book.
What did you really want to do?
When did you start the idea of even doing it?
Well, what happened was my daughter, she's a sea-steed.
But she knew I had all this material.
And she kept saying, why don't you put it together in a book?
And of course, I hesitated, you know, for a decade, I guess I should say.
And she passed.
And I guess the one thing was in my mind was what she said to me.
And so that is why I started working on trying to put it together.
Talk about the process of putting it together.
Was it tough putting the book together?
Well, once I had the organizational technique for it,
and I could just go through all the material and place them according to the outline that I had.
So having the material is what's important, you know.
And I had that.
So it turned out to be a fairly easy job.
The only problem that I had was that I didn't know anything about publishing a book.
Didn't really know who to go to, to talk to.
And what I saw was a company that had done religious books.
It was out of Columbus, Georgia.
And so my husband and I both decided after I had everything together,
we would take it to this company, which we did.
The publisher was really was fantastic, I can say.
What I hadn't anticipated was the people behind the publisher, you know, the copy seller,
who was, I can see now, white lady, who I guess didn't like all of this material that was in the book.
And I kept finding arrows, you know, and I would go to the publisher and tell them.
And well, I had to pay for every mistake that was there, as if I guess it were mine.
And so finally what happened, I always say God's deputy.
Because I sold out of the first edition.
And the second edition, we picked up the books like on a Friday.
And the company was closed now that weekend.
We had a book signing that Saturday, or Sunday, I can't remember which one of those dates.
But when we went through the book, we found a page where, you know, on the page where they're going to put a picture,
where the picture goes, they have a blank spot.
And the directions at the top says, drop him.
And they didn't drop the picture and print all those books.
Oh wow.
So I had a decision to make, well or not, I would accept the book, you know, in my mind.
And whether I would just not have the book signing.
But everything was so close until I said, well, I decided I would have the book signing.
I would explain about the mistake.
And once it was corrected, then the persons that bought books would get the corrected copy.
So that Monday morning, early in my husband and I went to Columbus, Georgia.
And well, the publisher knew that it was his mistake.
And that he would have to account for it.
He made all kind of offers to us so that he wouldn't have to redo the whole book.
But my husband would accept it.
So finally, he said, okay, I'll redo the book.
But when the book was printed, he didn't use second edition.
He used third edition.
Okay. So how did the community respond to your book?
I mean, the readers who were interested.
I can't say anything about the book.
They were fantastic, really.
That is why I guess the first edition went so far.
And then we got into, well, really, the fourth edition.
Okay. So what, I mean, you've talked a little bit about the process of creating the book and getting it published.
Do you think it accomplished? What were you trying to accomplish with the book?
Well, mainly to get information out.
I wish every black family had a copy of the book for their children.
But I tell you now, since then, I've thought about it.
There's a lot of writing in the book, even though it says a pictorial history.
And children like to look at pictures.
Could you hold the book up?
But they're not that fun and reading.
Right.
And since then, I have discovered that they're like poetry.
So what I'm doing now is a book on, it's really on all the movement.
But it's done in poetry.
Okay. And these are all be poems by you?
Yes.
Okay. Okay.
So the Albany movement, then, it's impact on the community.
Talk about that. How do you, do you, do you think it was successful?
Do you think there are some areas that are naturally, you know,
there's some work that still needs to be done?
What do you think it accomplished?
Well, I wonder how long it would have taken us to get where we are today.
Had it not been for all been a movement.
When I walk in stores or walking bags and seeing black people behind the desk,
this is what we accomplished.
Okay.
We might have gotten this far, but I don't know how long it would have taken
without the movement, you know, pressuring these issues.
And so I give credit to the movement,
of where we are today.
And we must remember, too, that the journey is not over.
You know, I look at, we've come so capitalistic, too.
And I think of Martin Luther King Jr and the legacy that he left us
of service and preparing young people for the future,
because it's the paternalists in their hands now.
And they must know what to do and how to do the things that need to be done.
You know, I was thinking about those young people who went into the bus station
that really was the beginning of the movement.
They didn't go there to break logs.
You know, they went there to enforce logs.
The ICC (Interstate Commerce Commission) regulation banning segregation in interstate-bus terminals.
And those six girls that went into all been a high school.
Simply because CB King struggled eight long years after the Supreme Court ruled
on desegregation in public school.
So, and then think now, the laws that helped us then,
are the laws that are being challenged now.
That's correct. Very true.
Okay. All right. Well, I thank you.
Is there anything else you would like to add to your story?
Well, I think I've said it, oh.
Thank you. Okay.
Well, thank you so much, Mr. Jenkins, for offering us your time to share
with you in the Civil Rights History Project.
Well, thank you. That was great.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.